so we actually think that this is hard
but we don't know how to prove it
and it tells us that we need stronger
assumptions to do that
so the PCB theorem even with all of the
extensions that we're going to see
seems insufficient to prove such
statements
so what we're going to do next is try to
discuss some strengthenings of the PCB
theorem that were studied over the last
30 years with the aim of coping start
statements we'll see what they get and
see how to get Beyond them
any questions so far
so to study these strengthenings I'm
going to make a different formulation of
the PCP theorem which is completely
equivalent it's just easier to see the
strengthenings once we use this language
of label cover
so here's the definition
so level cover is the name of a problem
a computational problem and an instance
of it proceeds as follows
so my instance I'm going to call it PSI
and it consists first of all of a
bipartite graph
I have left right L and right side l
then for each one of the sides I have a
separate alphabet Sigma is the alphabet
of the left side and sigma R is the
alphabet of the right side
and one last thing which is the most
important feature of a label cover
instance is the constraints
for each Edge in the graph I have a
constraint Phi which tells me which
pairs of labels to the left vertex and
right vertex are considered satisfying
and you see that there is this word
projection here
so
usually when you define label cover you
don't have this wall but you know we
want projection so I'm going to skip it
what is meant by bojacking is that these
constraints are not arbitrary rather
they have at least mild structure
namely for each add UV once I tell you
the label of the left side view there is
a unique label for the right side that
satisfy the constraint
or in other words there is a mapping
between
the alphabet of the left side and the
alphabet of the right side so that if I
assign the left die the value Sigma then
the right y Max gate get the value Phi e
of Sigma in order for the h to be
satisfied
so this is what a level cover instance
is
and of course if I give you a level
cover instance so this is a maximization
problem and now I'm going to Define what
is the objection what is the objective
function
of this problem well I give you a level
cover instance your goal is to assign
labels to the vertices
so that as many of the constraints are
satisfied
so I want to maximize the number of
edges in so that if I look at the labels
that I assigned to the end point of view
then this fall inside the collection of
tuples that are considered satisfying
so we'll see an example of how you can
recast suicide in this language this
language is a bit
let's talk about we've captured many
things and it's very useful
that's an example of how to capture
threes out in this language of laborator
and
for that we should have in mind some
threes at formula Gene
and right now I'm going to describe to
you how to construct this Viper effect
graph this alphabets and this
constraints so that the label cover that
we have essentially captures the
satisfailability problem of G
so how does it grow well I need to tell
you what is the left what is the right
what are the alphabets and the
constraints
well the left we're going to have a
Vertex for each one of the clauses
so these are these orange releases
so we're going to have a Vertex for each
one of the variables
now what are the alphabets well
for each vertex on the right is going to
get either 0 1 depending on if we want
to assign that variable zero or assign
it one
in other words assignments to the left
side
describe assignments to the violence
and assignments to the left side well
the assignment to each vertex here is
going to specify the assignments to each
one of the variables inside close
and I'm only going to allow seven of
those eight of the assignments those
that satisfy the clause
so this is how to think about the left
and the right and now the last thing
that I need to do is describe the
constraints
naturally well we if we have a variable
here X1
we are going to want the assignment that
this X1 gets to be consistent with
whatever it gets on the 200 vertex so
this is going to be the constraints of
the level cover instance
so we're going to have an edge between
each clause and each variable
if that variable is contained inside the
clause or it's negation
and we are going to demand consistency
so we're going to set a label for this
vertex
is consistent with this if they give the
same value to X1
and you can convince yourself that you
know in some high level perspective
this level cover instance exactly
captures
the satisfability of three such the
formology
it's not exact the value is not exactly
the same but it really captures it in
spirit
so whenever I say level cover you should
really think of this sort of instance in
mind but you know the definition is more
General
so now that we have this level cover
language out of the way I can tell you
an equivalent formulation of the PCP
theorem
the film that says the following
there is some absolute value okay and
Epsilon so that if I give you a label
cover instance well the alphabet size at
level constant there's more scale
then it's simply how to tell whether the
assignments to the level cover that
satisfy all of the constraints
oh
what assignments satisfied most
one exceptional fraction of the
constraints
so actually if you do the construction
that we did before because there's a
corollary of the previous combination
but it's really equivalent
changing last slide from the last minute
is not a good idea so I'm sorry about
that we're going to try to make it work
um
see
I hit the wrong slide
and anyway we have the basically theorem
and now we want to improve it
and well as I said this film is is
strong enough to obtain some results but
it's not strong enough to obtain all of
the results that you want
so we want to strengthen it and there
are two ways that you can think about
in order to do that
so one way is to improve the sound
experimental
so in all of this business I'm going to
have two parameters the completeness
which is what happens in the yes case
this is what you can do in the good case
and the soundness which is the best you
can do in the knowledge
so in the basic PCP theorem well
you cannot do one more exception but one
reception is still allowed and we want
to improve upon that
so this is what is called the low salmon
sodium and you can hope to prove that
maybe 11 cover is still hard even if you
want to distinguish between fully
satisfied instances and instances later
with most Epson satisfied
and this isn't the case we know how to
do that and this is proved using what is
called parallel repetition
[Music]
so this was known for a long time and
really all of the results that we saw
forward filling for click on all of that
they all they already incorporate all of
these machinery into the picture with
all this we cannot really do anything of
it
so this is one way you can try to
improve upon the basic PCB theorem
another way is more subtle
and in some sense we already saw it
so the constructing label cover are
fairly generic we don't have too much
structure over them
well I'm slightly cheating already
because
if you remember I said it's called the
projection constraints and clearly there
are more General families of constraints
and this projection world is very
important when you do reductions but
projection is still a very rich family
of constraints
so you can hope
to obtain stronger structure over the
constraints the more limited the better
and this is not obvious like you have to
look at reduction and see that they
actually use this structure a lot
but once you see enough of these things
it becomes clear that the structure of
the constraint is very important
and here unfortunately our understanding
is much more partial
and in some sense so people have been
doing this structural from long time but
it looks like a hack like every time
you see this world smooth file
repetition a smooth PCP so this is
basically a name for a hack to obtain
some structure of the constraint which
is just good enough to obtain the result
that the offers wanted
so here we have a complete understanding
of this a small value regime where the
structure thing is much harder
and as as his life if you want to obtain
the best results you actually have to
obtain both of these things
simultaneously
and I already said we cannot do it in
the best way
and indeed because we cannot do it in
the best possible way this Machinery is
still insufficient for many problems
so for example we
saw the world no discover this is one
prominent problem over these sort of
tools are not enough
and if you want to paint that results
you have to go even further
but before we go further the question is
so what would even be the ultimate
combination between these two
improvements how would it look like and
what would it give us
so we're done with the basic PCB theorem
well done with the consequences and I
did tell you what is the strong question
is given which is basically the small
soundness with some mild structure over
the constraints
now I'm going to tell you about this
ultimate combination between all of
these sex which has a name it's called
unique games
and this is a central problem in
complexity Theory
so what are unique games
well any game first of all is a
particular special type of a level cover
instance
and it has two additional features
first of all
that for bed sizes of the two sides are
the same
and in fact you should think of that for
which is just being the same
and secondly for each Edge this
a constraint between the alphabets is
just a matching it's the simplest
possible thing
simplest type of constraint you can
think of
or equivalently if you remember we said
that each constraint is defined by some
math
so matching there say that that map is a
one-to-one
again level cover language is a bit
abstract so let's see an example
so let's add it to about that graph
and let's say that the alphabets is just
some field FB
then what would be a unique game over
this uh graph well with the edges
unique for example says they value that
the left vertex gets minus the value of
the right vertex gets is equal to 4 mod
rupee
in that case whenever I tell you what is
the value of X1 there is only one value
for y1 that would satisfy the
constraints and vice versa
so this is a one type of thing again
actually in some sense it's the only
type of Union game but uh never mind
that
and whenever I see any games this is
really what you should have in mind
Okay so
we're not working in a games are now
and the only thing that is clear so far
is that
uni games are just very very special
type of label travel instances
so in principle they may be easier
computationally speaking
and for example here is one aspect in
which they are in fact easy
so if you remember we said it if I give
you a level cover instance it's hard to
tell whether it's fully satisfiable or
at most one percent
well for any games this is no longer the
case
if I give you a uni game instance and I
tell you that it's fully satisfiable
then you can just solve it you know in
polynomial time because you guess the
value for one vertex and then you
propagate it over the place there is
only one option each time you propagate
it
so this is easy
well so what do you do then well you
conjecture that besides this little
satisfability issue unigames are still
hard
and this is what is referred to as the
uni games conjecture or ugc in short
this was made by Sebastian 2002 and it
says the following statement it says
foreign
in other words the informal version of
it is if you ignore the satisfabric
ratio unigames of adjusters are this
label is general labor
and every silver thing because
well I'll explain it soon so NP hardness
is you know the gold standard silver is
you know silver is less than gold so
it's less so this is a conjecture it's
still a conjecture but there are many
Works saying well if this conjecture is
true then something else happens so
these are still very good results but
you know it's not NPR so this is the
distinction between gold and silver
and this is what I referred to as you
know the ultimate combination between
small Sounders and structure for the
constraints
because you see here the gap between the
S case in the north cases as good as you
can hope for but at the same time
I cannot imagine any you know
simpler type of constraints well this
problem can still be conceivably hard
so this is really the best of both
worlds
of course this is just a condition so
yeah so the CDC business have been has
been around the block for
a while now so naturally there's been a
lot of fork on it
and
roughly speaking you can partition the
work without any games into three types
so one of them has is algorithms
so you know naturally once you define
some computational problem you can try
to design algorithms for it
and indeed starting with the original
playable by subash people have been
trying to do it and
for some classes of graph it works for
some kind of see it works less well but
the bottom line is that all of these
algorithms were very sophisticated nice
they are not able to solve unigames in
general
so they don't bite the condition
but they do give us fairly nice ideas
about what we can hope that Howard Union
gamuts would look like or whatever what
they cannot look like
this is one type of works that they've
been about uni games
the other type is the type of form that
says okay let's assume that unique games
is hard what can we conclude about the
world using it
so here there are many more Works uh I
have only you know three citations here
but I don't want to flood you with you
know Brazilian I'm not a cryptographer
so uh
some very nice neat results of Thai
Thailand's results for vertex travel
so you're probably familiar with the
trivial to approximation algorithm well
you know to take an edge what it says
and repeat
algorithm is essentially tight if you
assume you're the same
this was a very nice walk
but and even I think more influential
work was this hardest result for Max cut
which really opened the flag dates for
consequences of winning games and
following this they'll win a lot of
works
and
I hope that I'm not offending anybody by
saying that probably the the most
notable result in this business has been
or the vendors Resort that basically
says that you can look at the class of
constraints satisfaction problems which
is you know a huge class of problems
and assuming you're the same for all of
these problems the best you can do is
semi-definite programming algorithm
so this is really you know amazing
result in my opinion like thoughts for
General class of problem is it tells you
what is the best algorithm and why you
cannot do better than it
so you know if you this is true then it
gives us a very nice understanding for
many many problems
and the last type of work is about
udcs you know it's a conjunction so
let's try to pull it
and there have been some attempts but as
a student is the best
or I guess the most uh
[Music]
I guess the best results that you know
about unigames is what is derived from
the two to one game theory
which is not equivalent but it's
basically equally into the following
assertion
which says that the Union against
currency is true but in this case you
cannot achieve one minus Epsilon but
rather some constant so it has
so
so this is the State of Affairs about
uni games
so let me elaborate a little bit about
this consequence of winning games so you
know we're in analysis of these years
semester so energy should enter the
picture at some point and I will just
say that behind every almost every one
of these consequences lies a very nice
analytical theorem with four
coefficients influences everything that
we like in this store
so here is an example this is the
expertise result
and here's what it says I give you an
inverted scarf
then it can be hard to tell whether
there is a vertex server that consists
of at most travel devices
must contain essentially all of the
vertices
whether this is this seems ridiculous
this is a consequence of winning games
in other words when you you know you do
this division problem you get that it's
how to
approximate to impact or two minus
foreign
based on semi-definite welcoming you
know it's a very nice algorithm and it
achieves some fun approximation ratio
for Max cut which is roughly this number
on the slide
and what you can show again assuming UBC
is that this algorithm is actually
current
in the sense that so every Epsilon
greater than zero
getting approximation which is just
Epsilon Metals is already
and finally I said that this very
general result
and a slightly more
a General charging precise formulation
of it says that if I give you any
conspirential extraction problem
then you can write down the
semi-definite program next session which
is a very something very generic
then you can solve it and then apply
some you know Blackmagic which is called
gaussian random schemes that you have no
control over but it exists and if you do
all of these things without even looking
at the instance too much you get the
best approximation possible
again assuming UDC
sorry you know what it is
I think the same version
yeah
yeah but the condition though how now
this information we can do it yeah
remember there is some yeah something
that is
I don't know
there is some funny things
by finite sizing since it's for any like
CSP with planetary right yeah yeah but
the question is like if the LED is scale
how how you should go I don't know it's
quite bad yeah
yeah something final but uh
foreign
[Music]
function Center so behind each one of
these results lies some very nice uh
analytical
film and many techniques have been
developed precisely to make these
reductions work
and let me give you an example for one
of these theorems probably the most
well-known one which is called majolic
extremist
so oh still no fault it's not going to
be one function but not for you
so let's say we have a balanced Boolean
function
and let's take some correlation
parameter along
I encourage you to think of four as
close to one say one more steps
I Define the stability of G of f to be
the probability that when I take X and Y
which I will correlated
so what correlated in this stock is
exactly as a Non-Stop in the max stock
the same thing you keep the coordinates
the same with 4x0 and otherwise it will
sample it
for example X and Y whichever correlated
then you ask what is the probability
that F assigns the same value to X and Y
so this is stability and the question is
what function maximizes the stability
among all balance functions
well this is a bit of a boring question
it just Spectators you know you see
indicators today many times
and it did if you just take f of x to be
equal to X1 you can calculate the
stability and you can prove that this is
the best you can do
so this is not an interesting question
and it turns out that for PCP the
interesting question is
what happens if you disallow dictators
in a strong sense
what happens if I impose on you the
constraint that F has no inferential
value
then it turns out that the answer is
much more interesting
and more speaking it says that among all
of the functions with small influences
the one that maximizes the stability is
the majority function
and
uses some very fancy analysis support
functions in particular
hyperconductivity which we've seen the
imbalance principle which we haven't
seen but probably will see at some point
in this semester
uh I should say that this helium has
multiple of me now some of these some of
these don't use any of these tools but
and get even better parameters but uh
we start to say that the motivation for
this statement became precisely because
of the study of ugc
and this led to development of nice I
need to take like two weeks
so
um
invented to solve this question yeah so
the
statements
the main motivation or the audio
motivation was udice
and yeah since then the inbox makes one
of the found many other applications
so
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
some progress about winning games which
is two to one games
so
what is it two to one game
so is everything in this talk two to one
game is a level cup instance
but you have some additional starting
so basically two to one game is
close to any games as you can get
without being big
in other words now maybe that for bits
are not the same but the left side is at
most is just twice as much as the right
side
and now if you look at the constraint as
the graph it's not a matching but it's a
2-1 regular box
so this is
a very natural
and here is an example
so again we have a usual picture we have
a background graph
and now let's imagine that the labels of
the left side are elements from f 2 to
the K plus one
and the uh maybe the K plus one should
be on the top it doesn't matter
so this alphabet is twice as large as
the example that think about that as a
vector with over F2 of a length K plus 1
and K
now how would a two to one constraint
look like with this regard well here is
one type of constraint you can look at
so suppose for each Edge I have some
Subspace so again this you should think
of it as F2 to the K plus one so it's a
vector space of dimensions
so imagine that for each add I have a
sub base of co-dimension one
then what I can do is look at the label
of the left side
project it onto that Subspace and ask
whether this is equal
to the vector on the on the right
so you can observe this because we are
in F2 and we did a project on the core
Dimension One this is a two to one
constraints because each for that Vector
has two lists two narrative space
so two to one games have been also
proposed by Court any conjunction but
they are also hard
and if you notice now we don't have this
satisfiability issue because
when you do the
[Music]
propagation algorithm technological
works so you can be optimistic about two
to one games and hope that maybe they'll
have even in the yes case we're asking
to satisfy all of the constraints and in
the novels we ask not to satisfy even
Epsilon function of the constraints
the formally speaking this is what is
called the two to one games conjecture
and the theorem which as I said
is equivalent to something roughly
equivalent to something about minigames
says that well morally speaking this
conjecture is true
except for the satisfiability issue
in other words foreign
so that if I give you a two to one games
instance sorry it's NPR to tell whether
it's almost fully satisfiable
namely you can satisfy one reception of
the constraints oh it's barely satisfied
namely you cannot even do Epstein
so let me quickly tell you what this
Theory does give you it doesn't give you
all of the Power Rafi gives you half of
the power of ugc
so here are some concrete examples
so as I said it gives you hard gap
between games within half an Epsilon
and you get some improvements for some
classical
optimization problems for example you
get the fact of square root of two so
both schedule
you get something for click and you get
something for Max Bank Max cut game
coloring problems and this and that
I don't want to talk about too much
about these applications I just want to
show you one of them
because this is the problem that we
started doing so if you remember I asked
you what happens if I promise to you
that you know the graph contains a click
of size half
well we cannot quite deal with that
right now but we can say that you know
some different number 0.29
so even if your graph contains a click
of that size you're not going to even be
able to find a click of size Epson
so this now we do know but you know
potentially this could go up to half
yeah so uh to infinity and beyond this
Buzz Lightyear said so
so I so now we are going to go into more
of the Boolean analysis type
questions and kind of ask yourself
so we got to talk about this uni games
business then there is this two to one
thing and I'm going to try to argue
that if you want to have any hope of
approaching UDC or even this two to one
you need to depart from these classical
Notions of hyperconductivity and small
cell expansion and go beyond that
so in the rest of the time that I have
I'm going to try to motivate why is that
is the case
and then in the next hour and maybe
tomorrow I'm going to say a little bit
more about it
but I know it's going to be you know
some very light motivation
but before that are there any questions
before we switch gears
ity
foreign
you have to use what is called L
collecting codes
and more specifically you have to talk
about locally testable called the goals
so what is a locally testable helical
thing called well first of all let's say
that I have a code C which is a subset
of Sigma to the n
I'm going to say that it is not really
testable if I have some tester p a
randomized tester
so the tester gets a Oracle access to
some world
s a few locations hopefully concert
demanding
and then based on multi-trades he
decides whether to accept object
and I want two properties to hold
first of all I want it to be the case
that if my tester C is being ran on an
actual codeword for my code see
then it's always going to accept
of course you can relax it too almost
always accept but for us we're going to
deal with the perfect cognitive case
so this is usually it happens just
because you design the test out in some
sensible way
and the more interesting part is the
sounds
and the sound is that I specified here
is for what is called small soundness
and it proceeds as follows
suppose I had some word w
ET if I run my test on it then it
accepts with non-egligible probability
data
and how can it be well one case is if I
took an actual codeword and maybe it was
a little bit a little bit and be
something to it then it is most likely
to be the case that the tester is still
going to accept with good probability
essentially this is the only way you can
do it
in other words
if T accepts the world W with some
non-negligible probability Delta
then it must be the case that W is
correlated with some actual codeword C
from the code
this is sometimes referred with the
local two Global phenomenon literature
but don't
do learn it too much
so here's an example probably one of the
more well known examples this is the
blam Ruby Ruben linearity as well and it
processes as follows
in this case with the code C which
consists of all of the truth tables of
all linear functions from Z1 to them to
zero one
so this is another quality code it's
fully legitimate
and you can ask how can we test whether
function is linear or not
so the maps natural test and this is the
tester that they propose is as follows
stick to inputs X and Y uniformly
condoms
and query the function at three
locations X Y and X plus one
and then just check that this values add
up just check that f of x plus Y is
equal to X Plus F of Y
and if so accept
so it's trivial to see that if f is
linear then the test passes with
probability one
and
total but not trivial to show that if
the test passes with slightly better
probability than half
so half field is going to be trivial
just Satisfied by a random function
so if you pass it will probably slightly
more than half then it must be the case
that you are correlated with a linear
function
so this is the type of test that you are
after
and let me just mention one more
parameter of Interest which is the
number of queries that the test domains
so in this test the tester looks at
three values of f
namely it needs to make three queries to
the one
and the number of queries that the test
of X is going to be important for us
so for the rest of the talk I'm going to
focus on testers see that only make two
queries
so I only allow you to look at two
values of the function or whatever code
we look at
so therefore this type of test is not
going to be interesting for us we're
only going to one two points
so here's a PCP conventional algorithm
which says that everybody believes that
this is true until we don't
and
so the conventional wisdom is that if
you want to pull the harness result for
some problem
let's say some constraints a distraction
problem
then in order to do that you have to
find a suitable code C
along with a testerone
and you need several properties to hold
first of all the tester has to be
complete and sound in the sense that we
just defined
secondly the tester so the tester you
know looks in some values does some
computation and decides whether to
accept the object so it turns out that
oh the conventional wisdom is that if
you want to use this test though to
prove harmless result from something
then the check that the tester does has
to be of the type that you want to do
for example if you want to pull harness
result for it's really you know
then the tester is going to have to look
at three locations
and check a linear equation in the few
of them
so as well so this is the first thing
that you want
the second thing is well you know L
collecting codes we think of them as
encoding some message by a longer string
and the conventional wisdom says that
you don't want the blow up of this
encoding to be too much
and
I should say it say that this reasoning
seems kind of inherent it seems that
there is no way around it
but the other is a bit more technical in
nature unfortunately I'm not going to be
able to
fully tell you why it's necessary this
is related to a step in this post that's
called composition where you take some
PCP you take your tester and you combine
them to get something nice
and when you look at it you see that you
don't want this blob to be too much
and here's actually a good point to
remark why
UDC makes our life easier when we prove
harness for potential results
because basically if you're willing to
assume UDC then you can ignore this
broad conditional
any blog
therefore if you want to design Harvest
results based on UDC you just need to
find the tester which is complete and
sound and uses the right type of
check and you're good
and if you heard the word long code then
actually you don't have even much choice
of what the code is just take long
audits if anything it will exist in a
long code so it doesn't leave too much
maneuvering space
so this is why
you see is nice to have but if you are
not willing to assume that then you need
this
blow up condition
and I would like to argue that
the two properties of the blow up and
the soundness are actually in tension
with each other
so I'm going to tell you that if you
want the test to be sound
then there is a graph that you can
associate with the test
the test to be a small expander
otherwise there is no way this this is
going to be some
on the other end
if you have only a small blower in your
code
it means that the code is less
advantages like you're being cheap with
the link so there are less advantages to
play around with
therefore this limits the type of
testers that you can choose
and naturally when you don't have too
much freedom in your testers this means
that you are going to have trouble
making this test graph that I'm going to
soon Define as muscle expander
so there is a delicate tension here
between one thing the test of the
business bundle but wanting it to be
cheap with the blow up
and this is where this conventional
wisdom is going to eventually break
we're going to have to give up on one of
these
I'm getting ahead of myself
okay so in the last five minutes I'm
going to tell you what this test stuff
is and tell you why small set expansion
seems inherent
so let's say that we have a code let's
see what the coordinate space is anal
now I'm going to define the graph whose
vertex says uh the coordinates of the
code
and I have an edge between two locations
if they can be queried by the tester
thing
so what is the test essentially doing
well it actually just picking an edge in
this graph
calling the two locations and asking and
deciding whether to accept the project
and my claim is that if you want your
tester T to be sound
then this graph GT has to be a small
expander
and the proof is going to be by picture
so let's move it so suppose this graph
GT is not small solid responder
therefore it means that I can find some
small set that has a lot of edges inside
it
for more sensible tests they have some
symmetry books so therefore once I have
one set I can find many sets so let's
say there's a bunch of sets that want to
ascend that are disjoint that together
have a large fraction of the vertices
and each one of them is individually
expansion which is one of the way from
one
then once I have this then I can show
you a word that passes the test with
nice probability but it's not
doesn't come from any code word actually
so what I can do is you know have these
sets
which one of them I can choose a
completely different code order
and assign the coordinates in a swan
according to C1 according to connect to
two and so on and so forth
then you can observe that because the
tester if it looks two locations inside
there's two it's only going to look
locally settle therefore it's going to
accept
and because you cover a lot of vertices
and inside each set a lot of the edges
stay in you can show that the tester
passes with content probating
but because of because each one of these
sets is small you don't actually have a
code word globally it's all a lot of
small code words
yeah so this basically completes the
book of why small cell expansion is
necessary if you want this practice
there to be sound
so so this is the mode if you want to be
sound you have to have an SSC
so easy
so it is it is necessary but what this
suggests is that if we want to get over
the server then we must give up on SSU
we need to work with graphs that are not
monster expanders and see how to get
over this hump and try to do some other
things
and in my next two talks the one after
this in 30 minutes and the one two more
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
how you can go beyond it and I'm going
to tell you about this glass on graph
and all of the things associated with it
which sort of uh
which again will motivated purely by PCB
perspective and while this lens of
global level conductivity really started
so I'm going to talk about this and
we'll see where we go
yeah so that's it next up thank you
are there any questions for though
something like that hold even for more
queries than two because
so it's more complicated to even
formulated
so for example friends you're lucky for
example for doing you're lucky because
somehow you can allow yourself a local
correct using the trick Tock so whenever
this is the case then this limitation
doesn't really exist but when this when
you're not so happy then I'm guessing
that some limitations
I don't know
uh
but this depends on what is the problem
you are trying to put balance for so if
you want support works for example in
small silence you need to take that high
alphabet you can always look trivially
if someone support like one over there
so
um
let's think though again
foreign